now that we know some trigonometry let's
use that trigonometry to to solve some
word problems so let's get started with
this is exciting this is a navigation
problem so I have a ship and needs to go
from point A to point B so let me draw
that so I'm going from point from point
A which is that point to point B let me
draw a nice big one not so big triangle
big enough there you go
wait cuz I need space to do my math so
let me see so this is point a point a I
will draw and move point A to point B so
this ship needs to go from point A to
point B and this problem tells us that
the distance between point a and point B
is 10 kilometers 10 kilometers so this
guy set sail and because of whatever
reason he's a bad navigator or though
the water is flowing faster maybe
upwards maybe the water is flowing in
this direction let me draw that in blue
so to show which direction the water say
the current is flowing in that direction
and he ends up off track he actually
ends up after 5 kilometers so he travels
for 5 kilometers let me do that in blue
green he travels for 5 kilometers and
after 5 kilometers he realizes that he
has gone off track and somehow I don't
know maybe using his astrolabe I don't
really know what one is but that's what
people use and when they're on ships to
figure out where they are I think he
realizes that he is 15 degrees off
course so he is 15 degrees off course so
what that means is that he's the the
between his the path he took and the
path he should have took is 15 degrees
at least that's my interpretation of it
so this is 15 degrees and of course he's
traveled 5 kilometers in the wrong
direction 15 degrees in the wrong
direction so what he needs to know is so
this is this let me let me draw a little
ship so this is where the ship is now
that's my ship so now this guy this poor
poor captain he should know how far do I
still have to go to get to point B
so let me so he needs to know how far is
let me pick a nice color how far is this
distance right here how far is this
distance this may just involve some
trigonometry so how can we figure out
this distance well let's let's just
break down what we know and that's how I
do drink problems I just keep messing
around with it until I get the right
answer so let's see if we can if we can
if we can tackle this problem that way
so what can we figure out we know that
this is five kilometers the site is five
kilometers we know that this is ten
kilometers we know this angle well one
thing I know I can figure out is well
let's let's just let's just make some
right angle so we can start using some
trigonometry so let's draw let me draw a
right angle here all right just drop it
straight down so can I figure out what
this side is right here let me draw that
in a different color it is brown color
can I figure out what this side right
here is well this side is going to be
what we did this is if we look at this
angle this is adjacent to the angle and
this is the hypotenuse so if we know the
hypotenuse we know the angle we want to
figure out adjacent what what trig
function should be used let me write out
down our sohcahtoa so Chi Toa sohcahtoa
so we know the hypotenuse we want to
figure out the adjacent so what involves
adjacent and hypotenuse Kaah or cosine
so we know that the cosine of 15 degrees
so I want to write over this just not to
waste space cosine of 15 degrees is
equal to this Brown side so let's just
call this I don't know I'm just going to
call it X all right so this is equal to
x over the hypotenuse over five right
and if we solve for X we get X is equal
to five cosine of 15 degrees oh well
maybe we made progress maybe we didn't
let's keep trying all right now let's
see if we could figure out this side of
this triangle well this is to this angle
this is the opposite right this is the
opposite and we know the hypotenuse so
what trig identity should we order a
trig function should we use well if we
know the opposite or if we want to
figure out the opposite and we know the
hypotenuse and we know the angle so what
trig function deals with up a new
opposition I was going to say I potenuse
but anyway what trig function deals with
the opposite and the hypotenuse well
that's that's sine right so the sine let
me call this Y we know that Y is equal
to well doing it the same way sign o 5
sine of 15 degrees all right I skipped a
step right because we could say that
sine of 15 degrees sine of 15 degrees is
equal to the opposite Y over the
hypotenuse over five and then go that
step takes us here we just multiply both
sides by five and you get Y is equal to
five sine of 15 degrees so that's pretty
cool we know this Y we know this X can
we figure out what this length is let me
draw it and yet another color can we
figure out what the length of this side
is well we know from the problem that
this whole length is 10 right we know
this whole length is 10 and we know that
this little part of it is X which is we
figure it out is five cosine of 15
degrees so let's call this Z we know
that Z is equal to 10 minus X right
because this whole thing is 10 this
thing is X so Z is equal to 10 minus X
and we already figured out what X is
equal to Z is equal to 10 minus this
that's what X is you don't even have to
use a variable X we could have just
written it like that so 10 minus 5
cosine of 15 degrees all right
that's this side Z is equal to 10 minus
5 cosine of 15 degrees so we know Z we
know Y this is a right triangle and
we're looking for this yellow side
whatever we want to call it that the
disk that's the answer to the problem
well this this this is starting to look
easy this is just the Pythagorean
theorem so let's just you know y squared
plus Z squared is
going to be equal to our let's just call
this I don't know let's call this M
picking an arbitrary letter let's call
that M so Y squared plus Z square is
going to be equal to M Squared so we
could just say let's just write that
down I don't know why I picked M really
just to confuse you I think so M squared
is equal to well what's Y squared Y
squared is 5 sine of 15 degrees so it
equals let me do it in that color 5 sine
of 15 degrees squared plus what's the Z
squared Z is this right Z squared plus
I'm running out of space 10 minus 5
cosine of 15 degrees squared and now I
just have to simplify this and if you
have a calculator I mean you could you
could do this without any simplification
but I want to get it as as simple as I
can so let me just so what's this
squared well this is equal to let me
draw a line here because I don't want to
get too messy but I need all of this
space so this is equal to what color am
I using now this is equal to I remember
this is M Squared we're going to take
the square root of all of this at the
end to figure solve for M so this is
equal to 25 sine squared of 15 degrees
or design a 15-degree squared that's
just how you write it and then we do a
little bit of foil here to expand this
so plus plus C 100 minus you know this
is just expanding this this expression
minus 100 cosine of 15 degrees plus 25
cosine squared of 15 degrees all I did
is I expanded I said well this whole
expression squared is equal to this
squared minus two times the two things
multiplied out so that's 100 cosine of
15
degrees and then I squared this last
term which is plus 25 cosine of 15
degrees if that confused you you might
want to review the multiplying
expressions so let's see if we can
simplify this further so if we take this
term and this term we could simplify
that to 25 times sine squared of 15
degrees plus cosine squared of 15 and
you could kind of skip all this and just
use a calculator and figure out this
exact value but I'm just going to keep
working on it just because I like to get
it as simple as possible before I use
the calculator so that term in that term
are that and then it's plus this stuff
plus 100 minus 100 cosine of 15 degrees
all right and then what is the sine
square root of 15 plus the cosine square
root of 15 that's one of our most basic
identities right that's that's the
Pythagorean identity and it's not a sine
squared of X plus cosine squared of X or
of theta is just 1 right so this term
becomes 1 and I'm running out of time so
I'll continue in the next video